[Music]
how's it going everyone it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and of course all things in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the past
couple of months have been pretty hard
due to the corona virus
most of the theaters around the world
have shut down and all of the studios
have shut down halting production on all
of their upcoming films and changing the
release dates pushing them back for all
the films that were about to come into
theaters the biggest upset of course was
Black Widow which would have come out in
less than a month from now and for a
while there we didn't have a new release
date for Black Widow but now we do and
not only Black Widow but new release
dates for four other films coming to
Marvel's phase four so essentially an
entire shift in Marvel Studios phase
four lineup so Black Widow has been
thankfully rescheduled to still be this
year it is going to be coming out on
November 6th and this is official from
Marvel Studios directly so unfortunately
it has been pushed several months back
obviously but we still get to see it
this year which is great because a lot
of studios have pushed some of their
films more than a year back so Black
Widow is actually taking the place of
the Eternals original slot so the
Eternals new release date is going to be
February 12th of 2021
so unfortunately now we have a little
under a year to wait for the Eternals
after that shang-chi and the legend of
the tin rings is going to release on May
7th of 2021 as well
we then we'll have Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness on November 5th of
2021 and then after that will be thor
love and thunder in february 18th of
2022
so unfortunately that one is a couple of
years away for us black panther 2 is
going to keep its original release date
and is still scheduled for May 8th of
2022
but now Captain Marvel 2 has been
actually pushed up a couple of weeks and
now will be coming to theaters on July
8th of 2022
it's exciting to finally get some
concrete details of what Marvel Studios
is planning for phase 4 and as you can
see they simply restructured it it
stinks that we have to wait a little bit
to see all of these movies but it's nice
to be able to go to theaters when it's
safe and not anytime soon where people
still be at risk but black widow is
officially not going to streaming or
video on-demand they are still playing
in the theatrical lease like we talked
about in a couple of videos and the rest
of Marvel is still on track just pushed
back a little bit so let me know how
excited you are to see black widows in
theaters like she deserves leave a like
for black widow coming to theaters and
don't forget to subscribe and
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on all things related to
Marvel and of course the MCU and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or ps4 and picking a
winner at 550,000 subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
fluff